[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم وتقبل الله صومكم قال المبعوث
الخاص للامين العام للامم المتحده الى
اليمن اسماعيل ولد الشيخ احمد انه لن تكون
هناك جنف ثانيه لكن المبعوث الاممي كشف
خلال مؤتمر صحفي بالرياض عن وجود مقترحات
جديده من الحكومه اليمنيه وقال انه سيصل
الى صنعاء الاسبوع المقبل للقاء الحوثيين
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما دلالات التراجع عن عقد جوله
ثانيه للحوار في جناب بشان الازمه
اليمنيه وما الخيارات المتاحه للحل بعد
تجديد المبعوث الاممي على تنفيذ القرار
باتت يوميات الازمه اليمنيه تتشابه
اعتداءات للحوثيين في مختلف انحاء البلاد
خصوصا في عدن والمقاومه تحاول بما توفر
لها من امكانيات التصدي لهم اذا المشهد
المتكرر لا يقتصر ايضا على التطورات
الميدانيه فالر تبه تسيطر كذلك على ما
يدور في اروقه الدبلوماسيه منذ فتره غير
انه يبدو ان شيئا ما يحدث هذه الايام ضغوط
خليجيه للخروج من حاله الجمود نفي اممي
لامكانيه العوده لجناب مجددا ومبادر
حكوميه للحل تقرير فتحي
اسماعيل ايه اوكي يبدو ان الغموض والشكوك
التي تلف افق التسويه السياسيه في اليمن
املت على المبعوث الدولي اسماعيل ولد
الشيخ كسر الصمت وايصال رساله الى اطراف
الازمه وهو الا تراجع عن تنفيذ قرارات
الامم المتح المحده ما يهمنا وهذا يعني
المجتمع الدولي كان واضحا فيه هو تنفيذ
القرار
2216 انا كما قلت في البدايه نحن كل ما
سنقوم به مبادرات يدخل في اطار ثلاث ركائز
اساسيه المبادره الخليجيه واليه تنفيذها
الحوار الوطني ومخرجاته وقرارات مجلس
الامن بما فيهم القرار
2216 ايا يكن الامر رفعا للحرج عن المنظمه
الدوليه المتهمه بعدم الحزم مع الحوثيين
او محاوله لاعاده تحريك مياه التسويه
الراكده فان تصريح المبعوث الاممي الذي
تضمن ايضا نفيا صريحا لاي عوده الى جنيف
ثانيه يعكس اعترافا ضمنيا ربما بواجهه
المخاوف التي تبديها السلطه الشرعيه من
امكانيه الالتفاف على مسعاها في اعاده
الاوضاع في اليمن الى نصابها قبل الانقلاب
الحوثي في سبتمبر ايلول الماضي وهي مخاوف
يزيد منها اصرار الامم المتحده على اطاله
امد المساع الس سياسيه دون تحديد افق واضح
او مهله زمنيه وصمتها عن عده انتهاكات على
الارض حتى خلال حوار جنيف وتزامنت تصريحات
ولد الشيخ في الرياض مع تقديم الحكومه
اليمنيه مقترحات للتسويه حملها الى
نيويورك وفد رفيع بدا اجتماعات مع مسؤولين
في الامم المتحده وعدد من سفراء دول مجلس
الامن ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي التي
تبدو ان رافعه اساسيه لتلك المبادره سباقا
مع الزمن واستشعارا ربما لجعل اليمن في
بند المساومات
والتسويات لا سما بين الامريكيين
والايرانيين تتالف مبادره الحكومه اليمنيه
من سبعه بنود اهمها انسحاب المسلحين
الحوثيين وتسليم المؤسسات للحكومه ووقف
اطلاق النار وايجاد قوات عربيه مشتركه
لحفظ السلام ون ششر تلك القوات يبدو في
سلم اولويات مطالب الحكومه اليمنيه من
الجامعه العربيه التي عجزت او تقاعست عن
دورها في اليمن بدليل تدويل ازمته ولعل
حظوظ تلك المبادره مرتبطه بما سيتبلور في
جبهات القتال اكثر منه بحسن نوايا الاطراف
الدوليه والاقليميه والرهان هنا على
المقاومه الشعبيه والقوات المواليه
للشرعيه فهو صمام الامان على الاقل لوقف
الانهيار والحفاظ على القضيه
حيه نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من الرياض
راجح بادي المتحدث باسم الحكومه اليمنيه
وابراهيم ال مرعي الخبير في الشؤون
العسكريه
والامنيه
سيد راجح بادي كيف فهمتم هذا الالغاء
عمليا ل جناف
اين
مساء الخير استاذ محمد اهلا وسهلا حقيقه
في البدء ارحب بما قاله السيد اسماعيل ولد
الشيخ انه ما يهم الامم المتحده الان هو
تنفيذ القرار 22 16 وهذا مؤشر جيد ان هناك
جديه لدى المنظمه الدوليه لتنفيذ بنود هذا
القرار الذي لنا الان قرابه 70 يوم منذ
تنفيذه منذ اقراره في مجلس الامن لم
ينفذ منه شيء حتى هذه اللحظه نحن كنا واضح
مع الامم المتحده ومع مبعوثها الامين
العام اننا حريصين على انجاح مهمتها في
اليمن لا نريد مزيد من الحوارات نحن في
اليمن يعني لدينا اكتفاء ذاتي من الحوارات
ومن الاتفاقات مع الحوثيين ومع صالح ما
نريده الان هو بدء مرحله جديده وهي مرحله
التنفيذ كذلك لا نريد الاجزاء في في في في
تنفيذ القرارات هناك مطالب ان ان القرار
لا ينفذ انما نبحث عن هدنا قلنا لا نحن
وصلنا الى مرحله اليمن لم تعد تحتمل حلول
جزئيه او حلول ترقيع نحن نرى ان قرار مجلس
الامن 221 هو منظومه متكامله شامله لكي
اذا اردنا فعلا واراد الاصدقاء في المجتمع
الدولي انقاذ اليمن وايقاف وقاف العبث
الذي يحدث في اليمن سواء في الدماء وفي
وفي الممتلكات علينا ان ان ان ننفذ قرار
مجلس
الامن بشكل كامل وليس البحث عن عن هدنه او
عن جزئيات بسيطه لا لا تحل المشكله انما
تؤجلها الى الى مرحله اخرى لذلك نعتقد ان
الامم المتحده يعني فهمت الرساله وبالتالي
لم يتم الحديث الان عن جنيف اثنين او جنيف
ثلاثه الان الحديث عن الاليه التي تقدمت
بها الحكومه وهي ليست مبادره جديده استاذ
محمد هي اليه تقدمت بها الحكومه ومفتوحه
للنقاش سواء مع الامم المتحده او مع الطرف
الاخر الانقلابين وص سعود سنعود لمزيد من
سنعود لمزيد من التفصيل لهذه الخطه التي
تقدمت بها الحكومه ولكن عندما ياتي
اسماعيل ولد الشيخ احمد السيد ابراهيم
المرعي ويقول انه لن تكون هناك جناف ثانيه
برايك ما الذي دفعه
الى الجزم بهذه
الطريقه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك اخي
محمد واحيي ضيفك راجح بادي وايضا مشاهدي
قناه الجزيره يا سيدي
الكريم الذي دفع ولد الشيخ اسماعيل احمد
ان اعتقد ان دول الخليج
والحكومه اليمنيه قررت ان تقود خارطه
الطريق
السياسيه للملف اليمني والا تترك هذا
الملف بيد موظف كبنك مون او موظف كولد
الشيخ اسماعيل احمد موظفي الامم المتحده
يجب ان يعلموا انهم موظفين لتنفيذ
القرارات ويجب الا تكون مبادراتهم خارجه
عن اطار قرارات مجلس الامن كما كان يفعل
جمال بن عمر ولذلك عندما تقرر دول الخليج
ودول التحالف والحكومه اليمنيه انها هي من
ستقود العمليه
السياسيه واوصلته الرساله بكل دقه الى ولد
الشيخ اسماعيل احمد وقالوا له ذهبنا الى
جنيف لاظهار للمجتمع الدولي ان الحكومه
اليمنيه وان كافه اطياف الشعب اليمني
والاحزاب السياسيه تريد السلام ولكن الطرف
الاخر ال
الانقلابيون مكثوا ثلاث ايام دون دخول
مبنى الامم المتحده وهذا مؤشر على عدم
احترامهم لا للمجتمع الدولي ولا لمجلس
الامن ولا للشعب اليمني وبناء عليه اتضح
من خلال هذا المؤتمر لدى دول مجلس التعاون
ولا دول التحالف لو ذهبنا يا اخي محمد الى
جنيف 1000 فلن ياتي بنتيجه مع هؤلاء ولذلك
اذا ارادت الامم المتحده واراد المبعوث ان
ينفذ وان يكون هناك فع فعلا سلام وامن في
اليمن فليتق ايد بقرار مجلس الامن 22 16
وليب حث عن تنفيذه وفقا للقانون ووفقا
لقانون واجراءات المنظمه في الامم المتحده
الان هذا القانون او القرار 22 16 تحت
الفصل السابع الماده 41 انظمه الامم
المتحده تنص انه اذا لم ينفذ هذا القرار
تحت الفصل السابع الماده 41 انه يرفع
تقرير من قبل الامين العام لمجلس الامن
وينتقل القرار تحت الفصل السابع الماده 42
لتنفيذ القرار بقوه السلاح هو هو حتى يعني
هو حتى اسماعيل يعني بعد اذنك يعني حتى
اسماعيل شيخ احمد ولد الشيخ احمد قال بان
القرار 221 وقرارات الامم المتحده بشكل
عام لها طريقان للتنفيذ اما المحادثات او
القوه ويبدو ان المحادثات واضح انها لحد
الان لم تاتي بنتيجه ينضم الينا الان من
تعز العقيد سمير الحاج الناطق باسم المجلس
العسكري في في تعز سيد الحاج بالنسبه
للمقاومه على الارض عندما يقول المبعوث
الاممي بانه لن تكون هناك محادثات اخرى
جديده في في جنف كيف تقبلتم
ذلك مرحبا بك استاذ محمد وضيوفك
الكرام في الحقيقه احنا في المقاومه على
الارض ربما لنا وجهه نظر اخرى فيما
يخص المشاورات وما يحصل في جنيف
والمباحثات ما يحصل على الارض شيء اخر
تماما رغم كل جهود السياسيين المشكوره الا
انه كل المعطيات والمؤشرات تقول ان هؤلاء
لا يريدون اي حل اطلاقا فاثناء الحوار
وقبل الحوار وبعد الحوار وقبل جنيف وبعد
جنيف الضرب مستمر القصب مستمر مر استهداف
المدنيين مستمر قصف المستشفيات مستمر حصار
مدينه تعز تماما مطبق ومستمر في يعني
الموضوع بالنسبه لمقاومه على الارض وللجيش
الموالي للشرعيه يعني تقريبا بعيد عن ما
يدور على الارض تماما يعني نحن نريد ان
يخرج البلد الى الى طريق يعني
سويه تقف الويلات على المواطن الموجود
الان لكن في المحصل لا نرى على الارض اي
تنفيذ لمثل هذه الاحاديث حتى كما قلت لك
في كل الحوارات اللي تتم يظل المدنيين وال
وجميع المواطنين في تعز وفي المدن اليمنيه
يعني عرضه للضرب والقصف ولا يعني هناك
وليس هناك اي مؤشر جدي على ان هناك اناس
يريدون ان يصلوا بحوار يعني ربما يخرج
البلد الى الى طريق امن بعيد عن هذا
العشوائيه في قتل الناس واباهم في الشوارع
انا مع متحدثك الذي يقول حتى لو عقدنا
جنيف 1000 لن يكون هناك اي نتيجه طالما
وان الاخر لا يحترم كل الاتفاقات هو دائما
ما اتهم الحوثيون بانهم يسعون دائما لكسب
الوقت سيد راجح بادي هل هل قرار الامم
المتحده قرار المبعوث الدولي بعدم عقد
جناب اثنين لا يعود فقط الى الاعتبارات
اليمنيه والخليجيه التي اشرت اليها وكذلك
ضيفنا السيد ابراهيم المرعي وانما ايضا
الى استنتاج الامم المتحده بان الحوثيين
وجماعه صالح ليسوا جديين عندما جاؤوا الى
جنف بدوا وكانهم سياح لم يذهبوا الى مقر
الاجتماع بدوا مبهورين بجنف ربما ذهبوا
الى التسوق ولكن لم تكن هناك اي جديه في
في تعاملهم مع
الموضوع نعم سيدي الكريم لم تكن هناك جديه
يعني لم يظهروا اي اي مستوى من الجديه ولو
بسيط يعني طيله ثلاث ايام وهم موجودين في
في جنيف باعداد كبيره يعني متجاوزين العدد
الذي كان مطلوب للوفد سبعه سبعه اشخاص
اعضاء الوفد اضافه الى ثلاثه مستشارين لم
يتم تقديم حتى اسماء الوفد المفاوض للامم
للمبعوث الاممي لكي تبدا المفاوضات لم تكن
هناك جديه ونحن كنا صريحين مع السيد
اسماعيل ولد الشيخ قبل انعقاد جنيف
واخبرنا انه الطرف الاخر غير غير جاد فعلا
في في في في التوصل الى اتفاق او الى
ايقاف حرب او الى ايقاف عدوان او الى حتى
هدنه حتى حتى الهدنه الانسانيه سيدي
الكريم التي توصلنا الى اتفاق بشانها
الهدنه الماضيه التي استمرت خمسه ايام رغم
المعاناه الانسانيه الا انهم منعوا من
وصول الغذاء والدواء للمواطنين المحتاجين
في عدن بالعكس سيطروا على على قافلات كانت
تنقل الدواء والغذاء وتم احراقها لكي لا
تصل الى تعز الى عدن الى الضالع الى لحج
سيدي الكريم نحن امام امام جماعه متوحشه
يعني خلال اليومين الماضيين كانت اول
سفينه تتبع منظمه الغذاء العالمي ستصل الى
ميناء الزيت الذي خصصته الحكومه لاستقبال
المساعدات الانسانيه وعلى متنها 3000 طن
من الدواء والغذاء من لاهالي عدن الذين
يعيشون وضع انساني ماساوي صعب للغايه قبل
ساعات من من وصول السفينه استهدفوا هذا
هذا الميناء وقبل الاستهداف هددوا الامم
المتحده انهم سيستهدف هذه السفن لذلك الان
على الامم المتحده مس مسؤوليه اخلاقيه
ومسؤوليه قانونيه يعني نحن البلد الوحيد
في العالم الذي لا تستطيع الامم المتحده
ان توصل حتى سفنها الى المحتاجين والى
المتضررين داخل الاراضي اليمنيه بسبب هذه
الجماعات الهمجيه الجماعات البربريه وياتي
الان ليقال لنا ونتحدث عن هدنه ما هل ايض
يعني عفوا عفوا هل هل الامم المتحده ايضا
وهنا انقل السؤال انقل السؤال ابراهيم ال
المرعي قبل قبل الفاصل هل هل هل ايضا
الامم المتحده لا تريد ان ان تتورط في
مسلسل في جناف شبيه بما تورطت فيه في
سوريا وبالتالي ليست مستعده لتراكم الفشل
هل يمكن ان نفهم ذلك باختصار لو
سمحت يا اخي محمد انا اعتقد ان هناك مشكله
في الامم المتحده اولا اعتقد ان هناك
تاثير لقوى خارجيه على سلوك المب الامين
العام وعلى اي مبعوث اممي سواء في اليمن
او في سوريا هناك توجيهات قد لا ترى من
قبل المتابع ولكن اعتقد انه ما يجب ان ان
يفعله الامم المتحده وما يجب ان يفعله
المبعوث هو ان يقوم بواجبه المنصوص عليه
في الانظمه والاجراءات في الاممم المتحده
عندما قامت الميليشيات الحوثيه على سبيل
المثال
بقصف السفينه التي ارادت ان ترسوا في
ميناء الزيت لم نسمع تعليقا واحدا من من
قبل الامم المتحده لذلك هي لا تقوم
بواجبها اذا ارادت الامم المتحده ان لا
تقع فيما وقعت فيه في كثير من القضايا في
العالم العربي فعليها التقيد
ب الواجبات والمهام المطلوبه منهم وان
يكونوا منصفين للشعوب وان لا يكونوا
ينساقون خلف
ا توجيهات خارجيه سواء اقليميه او دوليه
الشعب اليمني الان يا سيدي الكريم هناك
مذبحه حصلت في المنصوره لم نسمع من الامين
العام او من ولد الشيخ اسماعيل احمد تعليق
واحد وهو المبعوث للامم المتحده ولذلك
عندما لا يقوم بواجبه وينتظر ان ان تاتيه
التوجيهات لا نستغرب ان يقع فيما وقع فيه
في سواء في سوريا او في ما اي
منطقه ولهذا سيد المرعي ولهذا يبدو ان
هناك التوجه الحالي ل خريطه طريق سياسيه
واضحه او محاوله فرض القرار 22/1 بعد كل
مرحله التلك السابقه لنا عوده الى هذه
الزاويه بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام مازلتم
معنا في هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها
خيارات حل الازمه اليمنيه بعد تجديد
المبعوث الامي على تنفيذ القرار
2216 العقيد سمير الحاج في
تعز ننسى تعز في الوقت الحالي اذا سيد
راجح
بادي بالنسبه ل
القرار 22 16 الورقه التي قدمتها الامم
قدمتها الحكومه اليمنيه الان لتسريع
التنفيذ على ماذا ترتكز في نقاطها السبعه
اجمالا هي باختصار استاذ محمد هي اليه
لتنفيذ هذا القرار نحن راينا في السلطه
وفي الحكومه ان انه هناك هناك حديث متشعب
حول حول القرار نريد ان نوجه المسار الى
الى البدء فعلا بتنفيذ القرار ركزنا على
البند الاول والبند التاسع في في قرار
مجلس الامن 22 16 وهي الامور التي تظهر
حسن نوايا لد الطرف الاخر من ضمنها اولا
الاعتراف يعني هي ثلاث محاور نستطيع ان
نقسم الاليه المحور الاول وهو اعتراف جميع
الاطراف بالقرار 22 16 المحور الثاني بدء
بدء وقف اطلاق النار في كل جبهات القتال
الحديث المحور الثالث هو تثبيت هدنه
وايصال
مساعدات للمتضررين داخل الاراضي اليمنيه
وتحت هذه هذه الثلاث المحاور هناك تفصيلات
سواء فيما يتعلق بنشر قوات بعد
انسحاب الميليشيات المسلحه تسليم السلاح
خطه للاشراف وتنفيذ هذه الاشياء كان هناك
في اللقاء الذي تم امس مع مبعوث الامين
العا المتحده كان هناك نقاش بناء ورحب
بهذه الافكار وتحدث انه سينقل معظم هذه
الافكار الى الى سواء الى الامم المتحده
او الى الطرف الاخر اليوم هو توجه الى جده
للقاء القياده السعوديه ومن ثم سيتوجه الى
صنعاء والى مسقط للتفاوض مع الطرف الحوثي
وصالح سواء المتواجدين في صنعاء او
المتواجدين في في مسقط انا اعتقد ان هذه
الاليه وجهت الان مسار تنفيذ القرار في
الاتجاه الصحيح الاليه مفتوحه سواء
الاضافه او الحث للتشاور سواء من قبل
المجتمع الدولي او من قبل الطرف الاخر لكي
نبدا فعلا تنفيذ هذا
القرار الذي يعني طال امد امد منذ منذ
صدوره وحتى الان لم ينفذ منه شيء رغم انه
تحت البند السابع وصار موجب للتنفيذ حتى
بقوه السلاح بالنسبه للداخل اليمني العقيد
سمير الحاج هل هناك ايه امال معلقه على
هذا التوجه الجديد للحكومه اليمنيه ولدول
الخليج لاستعاده زمام الامور من الناحيه
السياسيه
هو الامل قائم والحقيقه الناس عايشين على
مثل هذا
الامل رغم انني استطيع اقول
[موسيقى]
وبمرارة صار مطبق وفتره طويله الان الان
لا خدمات لا مياه حتى المستشفيات بدات
تضرب حتى العلاجات بدات تنفذ يعني الوضع
الصحي غايه في في السوء يعني فهذا كله
يبعث على نوع من يعني نوع من الاحباط
حقيقه لكننا بهذه الاليه الجديده الحكومه
نتمنى ان تكون خطوه اولى ايجابيه وبتحرك
الاخوه ايضا في الخليج ربما الى الامام
خطوه نخرج الى الى يعني فك لهذه الضائقه
اللي يتعرض لها المواطنون اليوم في في كل
محافظه الجمهوريه وبالذات في تعز يعني على
وجه الخصوص نعم سيد الحاج هل هل تعتقدون
بانه في النهايه من سيحسم الوضع على الارض
هو الذي سيفرض شروطه بغض النظر عن كل هذه
المساعي
السياسيه والله معطيات التاريخ تقول مثل
هذا ونحن في في المقاومه الشعبيه سواء
المقاومه الشعبيه او الجيش
نعتقد انه في الاخير المقاومه لابد ان تصر
ان تنتصر اليوم او غدا او بعد غد هذه
مساله بالنسبه لنا مساله يعني حتميه ولا
نقاش فيها لا مشكله حولها لكننا كنا نتامل
اذا استطاع السياسيون ان يجدوا الحل والا
في الاخير سيظل الخيار هو خيار حسم
الموضوع على الارض وهذا ما اعتقد ان
الحوثيون والمخلوع يعني يراهنون عليه ولم
يستطيعوا ان يحققوه الى الان لكننا برضه و
في المقاومه نقول انه ان شاء الله على
الارض لا بد ايضا ان تحقق اشياء تدعم
السياسيه نعم هناك ايضا وجهه نظر سيد
المرعي في نهايه البرنامج تقول بان هذه
العوده ان صح التعبير للحكومه اليمنيه
ولدول الخليج لاستعاده زمام المبادره
السياسيه في وقت يراوح فيه الوضع الميداني
مكانه هو في نهايه المطاف محاوله لتجنب ان
تكون الورقه اليمنيه ورقه تستعمل الان في
المحادثات الامريكيه الايرانيه الى اي مدى
هذا الكلام يمكن ان يكون
صحيحا بلا شك اخي محمد دول الخليج ودول
التحالف لا ترغب والحكومه اليمنيه لا ترغب
بان تكون اليمن ضمن الاوراق التي تتلاعب
بها الدول العظمى في اي تسويات اقليميه او
دوليه وهذا شيء واضح وانت يا اخي محمد
اشرت الى نقطه مهمه جدا يجب على نعم ارادت
الان دول الخليج والحكومه اليمنيه ان تاخذ
زمام المبادره وان تكون من تقود خارطه ومن
ترسم ملامح خارطه الطريقه السياسيه الملف
اليمني ولكن يجب ايضا ان يكون هناك
انتصارات على الارض ولا ننسى ان الحوثي
وصالح حققوا جزءا من هذه الانتصارات في
ثاني ايام مؤتمر جنيف عندما
سلمت عاصمه الجوف مدينه الحزم لهم في ثاني
ايام مؤتمر جنيف وكان لذلك تاثير على على
المؤتمر ولذلك انا اعتقد انه يجب ان يواكب
هذه عمليه السياسيه يجب على دول التحالف
وعلى المقاومه الا تخفق في عملياتها
العسكريه وهذا مهم جدا وفيما يخص القوه
العربيه المشتركه التي ذكرت في مقترحات او
ورقه التي قدمت من قبل الحكومه اليمنيه
فهي ذكرت في الفقره الخامسه من البيان
الختامي لمؤتمر الرياض طلب قوه عربيه
مشتركه لتامين المدن الرئيسيه والاشراف
على تنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن 22 16 ولكن هل
هل كل هذا هذا التلكؤ في العمليه السياسيه
يعود في النهايه الى ان عاصفه الحزم لم
تكن حازمه في الحسم العسكري وبالتالي
الموضوع نوعا ما تميع في
اليمن يا اخي محمد يجب ان نعلم ان هناك
نقطه مهمه لم تتحقق الى الان واعتقد ان
عدم تحقيقها هو ما
وضع قوات التحالف او قياده التحالف في هذا
المازق
ما هي انها لم تجد ولم تؤمن منطقه امنه
على الاراضي اليمنيه ويجب ان تقوم بهذا
العمل مهما كلف الامر وقد تكلمنا مرارا
وتكرارا سواء على قناه الجزيره الموقره او
على اي وسائل اخرى انه يجب ان يكون هناك
مدين اذا وجدت مدينه امنه كعدن من هنا
يكون هناك الانطلاق الحقيقي لاي عمل عسكري
وانساني وايضا تكون ورقه رابحه في اي تس
سياسيه وفي تنفيذ القرار 22 16 ولكن الى
هذه اللحظه ما زالت المقاومه في عدن تراوح
ما زال في ايديها اربع مديريات في مارب ما
زالت في وضع دفاع في تعز ما زالت
المقاومه في وضع دفاع ولذلك اعتقد اذا
ارادت القياده التحالف السياسيه ان تنجز
او ان ينفذ القرار 22 16 يجب ان يكون لها
موطئ قدم على الاراضي اليمنيه شك شكرا
لضيوفنا ابراهيم المرعي من الرياض العقيد
سمير الحاج من تعز وراجح بادي ايضا من
الرياض في امان
[موسيقى]
الله